one sign that you've really made it is
that one of the phrases that you created
is now in the urban dictionary the urban
dictionary recently added noise and oh
why Cee which you guys that's you know
oh no the urban dictionary already
screwed up screwed up
yeah he's n oh oh I see II so that's
that's already messed up all right but
that that was if I were you I would I
would just take in the urban water nari
we don't want noise no noiseless in the
ether that was an observation we we made
on our sketch but like you said what's
it really credit for it doesn't know
what noise is once you tell tell them
what it's all about
well noise noise just means noise simply
means something that is incredible
beyond words so what we've done is given
a word to that which cannot be just
expressed so if you see something that's
more made to amazing for words you just
go oh it's just some physical human
display of yeah I do okay well let's say
I think it's in the urban dictionary and
I spelled it wrong it's right yeah
cody's writers got it writers got it
wrong they're the ones that tell me how
to spell stuff yeah you've also invented
other sayings and that and there's one
that I don't know Armenian conveyor belt
you guys use that in a sketch what's the
Armenian conveyor there was a stitch
where is called bump up up up and the
premise of the sketch is the only thing
you say real about conveyer belt no I
mean well that's a lot of this is
hanging out with Keegan because he has
his own language
Keegan ease yeah like if we're in the
trailer getting our makeup on in the
morning he'll just for no reason be like
it's poison like that's that's and and
but for him right conjunctions are
scoffs poison yeah yeah I speak in
adjectives all the time and I just say
thing and everybody now in the trailer
knows what I'm talking like guys let's
get out there and scoring too late this
Jam we got to take it out and they all
know exactly what I'm talking about yeah
I'll know what to do it's like what it's
like working with a Christmas elf
[Laughter]
so what is the Armenian conveyor belt so
that would be an imaginative imaginary
sexual act well I guess it's not
imaginary but in this in this Pacific
sketch bump up up up I was a character
who was trying to get a guy at his
bachelor party and the other bachelors
to engage in sexual act with a stripper
you know yeah so it's like bump up up up
you know your arm in front of you you're
in front of me she's in front of me
she's in front of you bump up up up
and the guys start to go away like women
so and where is she again mercy quick
into various new video and meaning
conveyor belt you're in the front I'm in
the back she's standing over there put
him over here I lay on top of you
Armenian conveyor bills I think it was
actually improvised in I really there's
no judgment on Armenian bull and we just
need a word Armenian conveyor belt and I
think those and then the Albanian water
hose it's random it's really random
anything Bulgaria and Macedonia
it's all from the Balkans
you